hello guys
Gregory here so Comic Con has been
underway and yes we've gotten Wonder
Woman traitor Justice League trailer now
a trailer has been released for a film
that I have really been looking forward
to I have been like reading a bunch of
articles on it and everything it's from
the writers of Godzilla on the latest
Jurassic world
it's from director whose work I'm not
too familiar with you might do the Metal
Gear Solid movie anyway we're talking
about the reboot of King Kong Kong Skull
Island which will eventually tie into
Godzilla apparently Tom head Liston is
in this let's watch this Comic Con
I'm glad you release this move dirty job
just chop it a minute now
uh-oh your joyride Wow it's really
really dark
modern day huh I know Djokovic to this
you are going to tell me everything I
don't know
I'm gonna blow your head off okay ah
this planet doesn't belong to us
each species owned deserve long before
mankind
Sam here trying to prove the truth
monster sixes
you go to someone's house unless you're
bigger
well you're looking at from some bygone
era Spanish event may
whoa [ __ ]
I will be there and I max my friend Wow
my nipples are so hard from the amount
of chills seriously like co-rec this
nipple is erect nipples
you know since Peter Jackson's King Kong
I like King Kong's associated as it's
like really big adventurous plot on
Skull Island this looks like a really
menacing dark haunting kind of
experience like there's something very
sinister about the tone here Sam
Jackson's one of those actors that when
I see him in trailers I'm very
distracted that it's Sam Jackson usually
though when it's in him when he's in a
movie I'm not distracted I usually get
pulled in and I like what he does I'm
wondering if this is gonna do the same
thing that the Godzilla movie did where
you don't really see much of King Kong
in it I don't know if that'll work as
well oh you know because they're just on
an island and it's King Kong's home and
it's just like hey there's a giant
[ __ ] ape here cinematography Manas is
this really creepy vibe very yellow
really yellow looking my I mean I don't
know if this movie we're gonna see as
much of King Kong I would like it if the
trailers didn't really show us King Kong
that would be cool I know at some point
they're gonna show us where King Kong
looks like but I would really like it if
the trailers just you know don't really
show us that much and then the movie you
know takes its time to really reveal
King Kong because school islands cool
because it's more than just King Kong
there's a bunch of other monsters too I
think John Goodman is one of the best
actors we have around right now I think
as a John reactor he's really good I
mean he was in the sci-fi film 10
Cloverfield Lane
[ __ ] perfect in that movie I feel
easy to kill it here Tom Hiddleston it's
pretty cool to see him like getting like
badass lead action hero role never gets
to show off his guns and then use actual
guns Marie Larson I think this is a good
step in the right direction for her too
in terms of coming off all that Oscar
[ __ ] and then now doing something that's
a big Hollywood film I really hope that
they give her a character that gets to
shine though I must have missed him
I know john c reilly is supposed to be
in this movie too and i have that just
makes me really want to watch it i love
john c reilly I heard King Kong they're
gonna make him like a lot bigger this
time a lot larger so that way he can
match the size of Godzilla when he
finally fights him I really hope this
movie doesn't work hard on tying it into
its cinematic universe with Godzilla I
would like this to just be its own
[ __ ] film and please just focus on
that it's pretty cool that's taking
place during the Vietnam War era I mean
it does have that vibe of a film that
would take place during that time it's
interesting combining that tone with
this world of Scola
point anyway Warner Brothers you guys at
least a [ __ ] ton of trailers today I'm
sure you got more come in somewhere yes
subscribe today become a reject
comic-con has overwhelmed me I really
need to you know go hit the sauna sweat
outs and toxins so I can produce more
sperm for my genetic programming that
I'm working on if you're new to the
channel subscribe and become a reject
and I am going to get to editing this so
this meal